é bom todo mundo tá passando por um
momento na vida para uma fase na vida
não é um momento muitos momentos na fase
da vida extremamente diferente de tudo
que a gente está habituado né com uma
série de desafios e uma série de
questionamentos que são meio que
inevitáveis agora é e uma das coisas que
as pessoas ficam um pouco complicado
fica um pouco questionando
principalmente é o que que eu faço com o
que está acontecendo nesse momento é
exatamente isso vai depender um pouco da
opinião de cada uma das experiências de
vida de cada um mas existem certos
fatores que são meio que universais que
se aplicam para todo mundo dentro dessa
experiência então nossa geração né vamos
dizer assim a geração das pessoas entre
0 e amizade em todos os 60 anos
o que foi poupada de grandes desafios
internacionais né se você parar para
pensar a geração dos nossos avós a
geração dos nossos pais para mostrar a
mais velha uma geração que teve que
enfrentar duas guerras mundiais é
importante a gente tem que ir para nós
para nossa geração essa é a primeira
grande crise global né a gente fica por
de guerras mundiais e tal mas a gente
nos capô peça essa é a nossa primeira
grande crise que têm uma repercussão
para todo mundo não interessa quem você
ela me interessa qual hotel a sua
sexualidade ali interessa a cor da sua
pele não interessa no que você acredita
se você é rico sua ser pobre altamente
como a pandemia vai afetar as pessoas
depende muito de todas essas coisas mas
em geral todo mundo de uma forma ou de
outra tá sendo afetada pela pandemia
e morreu o porque tem entes queridos que
estão doentes ou porque estão presos em
casa sem poder sair né e uma das
perversidade dessa pandemia é que como a
gente pode transmitir o vírus não temos
sintomas né pelo assintomáticos a gente
pode a gente pode estar sempre sem saber
contaminando as pessoas em volta da
gente a nossa família os nossos amigos
mais queridos por isso que é tão
importante essa história do
distanciamento social entendeu porque a
gente pode
e tem querer estar afetando e
e infectando na verdade as pessoas que
estão a nossa volta que é uma coisa
realmente terrível então quando a gente
fala de estacionamento social e que
infelizmente algumas pessoas no nosso
país em outros países não estão
respeitando é por causa disso é porque a
gente quer preservar nossa saúde só mas
a saúde das pessoas em torno da gente
agora existe uma tensão muito profundo
aqui porque a gente nunca teve que
passar tanto tempo longe de todo mundo
né que as eu tô aqui falando para vocês
mas eu tô falando e do norte dos estados
unidos quer dizer uma coisa eu não tô aí
com vocês presencialmente né aqui é o
marcelo gleiser virtual então esse dia
estacionamento é uma coisa muito difícil
ser humano porque nós somos seres
necessariamente sociais né a gente
precisa existe um grupo a gente precisa
olhar um no olho do outro não através de
uma câmera mas através de carne para cá
entendeu de
em frente não é aquela coisa da gente se
tocar da gente se ver a gente se abraçar
ainda mais uma cultura latina ser teu
caso educado do brasil na itália na
espanha né esse são países que você tão
vendo o seguinte são países que estão
tendo uma incidência de casos muito
grande né e o brasil ele está em
ascendência no momento quer dizer eu
acho que a situação aí vai ficar um
pouco mais complicado ou muito mais
complicada talvez daqui a uma semana
duas e temos meados de maio então é
importante todo mundo tá meio preparado
para isso nela e a gente fica meio
desnorteado né porque a gente tem essa
quebra de rotina ea percepção do tempo
da passagem do tempo ela é profundamente
influenciada por essa quebra de rotina
né a gente fica meio sem saber o que
fazer né então por exemplo
e as pessoas eu tô em casa então eu vou
ficar o dia inteiro de pijama e não vou
fazer a barba e não vou arrumar meu
cabelo né aquela coisa então vários
especialistas estão dizendo que isso não
é uma boa pessoal que esse negócio ficar
em casa de pijama é péssimo para cabeça
da gente por quê porque você passa a
entender a perceber a passagem do tempo
como uma coisa de ar hoje é domingo de
manhã entendeu eu vou ficar na minha e
tal e não é domingo de morais segunda
terça quarta aqui até sexta então a
gente precisa desistir porque mesmo que
a gente vai trabalhar de casa e ninguém
esteja vendo direito o que que você tá
usando e tal e na cabeça da gente a
gente tá tão programado para seguir uma
rotina profissional no dia a dia e esse
rompimento dessa rotina tem um efeito
psicológico bastante negativo você fica
com uma queda de produtividade você fica
meio sem saber exatamente que horas são
que dia
esse é o que que eu tenho que fazer nem
então você tem que ir tentar dentro da
medida do possível manter uma rotina no
dia a dia é fundamental isso só se você
tá em casa com os filhos no meu caso por
exemplo tem dois filhos estão sendo
escolares em casa entendeu e mesmo assim
olha isso eu dou minhas aulas para 120
alunos no momento online então eu
preciso ter essa esse essa rego esse
essa regulagem temporal isso é uma coisa
muito importante então manter a rotina
manter o controle sobre a passagem do
tempo é importante porque assim a gente
sim poder isa entendeu se a gente deixar
ausência da rotina a mudança profunda
dia a dia atual da cabeça da gente a
gente vai ficar confuso a gente vai
ficar deprimido a gente vai ficar
sentindo cada vez mais isolado das
pessoas
e tem muitas pessoas que não têm eu
diria a sorte e ter a família por perto
e para essas pessoas fica mais difícil
ainda você regular essa passagem do
tempo né então é importante a gente
entender isso dentro dessa concepção
atual da pandemia e também tem uma dose
muito grande de paciência então é muito
importante a gente tá preparado para
entender que essa é uma guerra contra o
inimigo que não faz a menor dissociação
entre quem você é da onde você vem e no
que você acredita entendeu vai ser um
inimigo invisível que cá entre nós
contribui eu deveria estar contribuindo
para a gente fazer uma auto-reflexão que
é muito necessária nesse momento no
século 21 de quem nós somos né não só
para concluir vamos falar um pouco sobre
isso que eu acho muito importante é
nossa
o planeta historicamente a relação
predatória é nós seres humanos sempre
somos os predadores é os parasitas a
gente olha para a natureza não como uma
parceira mas como um objeto de
exploração e por causa disso quê que
acontece a gente está explorando cada
vez mais a natureza achando que a gente
pode controlar todos os ritmos naturais
mas é óbvio que isso não é verdade
existem vários fenômenos naturais que
escapam nosso controle né desde o
maremoto o grande tempestades e tal e
obviamente a briga pela vida porque a
luta pela vida ela é interessante ela
continua sempre então esse vírus ele não
tem uma missão eu quero acabar com seres
humanos não é nada disso ele tem a
missão de o vírus quando se junta com
uma célula se reproduz e a missão de ler
as eu vou me reproduzir ela me tão
essencial da vida é reprodução então
essa batalha ela tá sempre
o w e o que que aconteceu com essa é
essa batalha esse coronavírus
infelizmente a gente não tava preparado
ninguém tinha vacina ninguém tinha é
anticorpos a gente não tinha a menor
defesa imunológica com relação a isso
então pegou a gente surpresa e mostra a
nossa fragilidade enquanto espécie então
é importante a gente entender isso que
apesar de tudo que a gente acha que nós
somos máximo entendeu nós continuamos
fragens perante a briga da vida né e
isso é uma coisa que a gente deve
entender todo dia por quê porque isso
gera uma certa o deveria pelo menos
geral uma humildade na nossa relação com
os outros seres vivos em vizinhos aí tá
mostrando o quanto nós não temos o poder
sobre ele né e todas as outras formas de
vida e a nossa relação com o planeta que
tem que deixar de ser parasítica para
ser uma relação construtiva
a samsung ótica da gente entender quais
são os nossos limites quais são os
limites de exploração do planeta e forma
que a gente possa juntos nós como
espécie a tribo humana e não as várias
tribos que a gente se divide o tempo
todo a tribo humana possa sobreviver e
manter uma qualidade de vida que a
sustentável entendeu e para nós e para o
planeta porque o planeta terra não tá
nem aí para gente entendeu ele tá existe
há quatro milhões e meio de anos mas nós
tem esse planeta a gente não existe
então a gente tem que respeitar a nossa
dependência do planeta e entender a
nossa codependência como nós todos
dependemos uns dos outros nós seres
humanos nós somos uma grande colmeia
humana e por isso cada um de nós tem uma
função fundamental cada um de nós pode
ser um agente de mudança cada um de nós
pode entender e ele ou
oi pode sim fazer uma diferença profunda
não só na vida pessoal na vida das
pessoas estão em torno da gente e
essencialmente na vida de todo mundo
nesse planeta porque obviamente nós
somos um só e essa crise tá demonstrando
isso de uma forma muito óbvia e muito
profunda e eu espero de uma forma
transformadora também